COMMITTEE ON TRANSPORTATION --
WE LIKE TO HAVE ROLL CALL PLEASE.
WELL -- FELL HERE BATES HERE
BATES PRESENT DOT.
DODD PRESENTS GALGIANI.
MCGUIRE MORALE.
MORALE PRESENT ROTH.
ROTH PRESENT RUBIO SKINNER STONE.
NUMBER.
I'M BURKE PRESENT WHAT CASTING.
BECAUSE HE PRESENT.
THANK YOU FOR SOARED BUSINESSES
TO ADOPT THE RULES RULES HAVE
BEEN APPROVED BY THE SENATE DOES
THERE ARE.
SAME AS LAST YEAR -- WE ADDED
SOME LANGUAGE -- WE HAVE A
MOTION TO ADOPT THE COMMITTEE
RULES.
OKAY THERE'S A MOTION -- WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE COMMITTEE RULES
WILL BE A JOB THE WILL NOW GO TO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR WE HAVE
FOUR ITEMS.
ITEMS ONE TWO THREE AND FOUR
PLEASE.
AND WE HAVE A MOTION TO APPROVE
THE CONSENT CALENDAR THE
OBJECTION.
OUR CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
WELL.
I WELL I BATES HI BATES AYE DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI [inaudible]
MCGUIRE.
MORRELL HI MORRELL AYE ROSS.
ROSS ICE RUBIO.
I RUBIO AYE SKINNER.
STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER.
WE CASKEY.
CASKEY AYE THANK YOU WILL GO TO
ITEM FIVE CENTER ARCHER LETTER.
IS -- MAKING HIS PRESENTATION ON
THIS IS SB OF FOUR OH FIVE
RECLAIM AUS FULL PAYMENT -- BY
THE PROJECT COUNTY LOS ANGELES --
SIR ARCHERY HAVE A FLOOR TO MAKE
YOUR PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M SO
HONORED TO BE BEFORE YOU THIS IS
MY FIRST DAY OF PRESENTING BILLS
THAT I THANK YOU SO VERY MCH.
AND I APPRECIATE.
YOUR HOSPITALITY AND WARMTH THAT
I'VE RECEIVED AS A NEW FRESHMAN
SENATOR.
AND TODAY I AM HERE TO PRESENT
SENATE SENATE BILL.
FOUR OH FIVE IS ONE OF THE FIRST
BILLS I PRODUCE THE AND I
CONSIDERED TO BE ONE OF THE WHAT
WE CALL A DISTRICT BILL BECAUSE
I THINK IT AFFECTS EVERYONE OF
OUR DISTRICTS.
IN REALITY IT'S A DISTRICT BILL
FOR ALL OF US AS I HAD MENTIONED.
FOR THE PAST DECADE I'VE SERVED
THE CITY COUNCIL AND MAYOR AND
CITY PEAK RIVERA.
IN EVERY DAY I SAW HE KERRY
ATION OF OUR STREETS AND
ROADWAYS JUSTICE IN YOUR
DISTRICT AT HOME.
FORTUNATELY SB ONE WAS ENACTED
IN NOW BEEN IMPLEMENTED.
AT ONE BILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR
AND HAS BEEN EARMARKED FOR
STREET REPAIR AND WE HAVE BOTH
TATIAN.
OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS THIS
WILL RESULT IN REPAYMENT OF
THOUSANDS OF ROADS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
THE FLIP SIDE TO THIS POSITIVE
STORY IS THAT MILLIONS OF TONS
OF ASPHALT PAVEMENT WILL BE
STOCKPILED THROUGHOUT OUR
COMMUNITIES.
THERE IS NO SECONDARY MARKET FOR
THIS MATERIAL IT JUST KEEPS
STOCKING UP PILING UP AND PILING
UP.
IN THE PAST RECYCLED ASPHALT.
OR GRANDES WITH A GREAT CHOICE
FOR US IN THAT BASE BUT IN IN --
IN THE BUILDINGS OF NEW FREEWAYS
HOWEVER WE HAVE A PROBLEM TODAY.
BUT WE ARE NOT GOING TO DO THE
RIGHT THING IF WE DON'T LOOK AT
WHAT WE HAVE FACING US RIGHT NOW.
SB ONE IS ABOUT MADE HIS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE AND I'M TALKING
ABOUT THE FUTURE OF OUR CITIES
ARE COMMUNITIES AND THE HEALTH
OF OUR CITIZENS.
CALTRANS CURRENTLY ALLOWS FOR
SMALL AMOUNTS OF DRY NEEDS TO BE
ADDED TO VIRGIN ASPHALT IN
STREET IN REAL BILL
REHABILITATION PROJECTS.
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES --
LOCKED UP 250% RECYCLED MATERIAL.
BUT IN BOTH CASES YOU STILL HAVE
LARGE AMOUNTS OF WRITINGS THAT
NEED TO BE STOCKPILE.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT TO
JUST SHRUG FOR THE RECORD THAT
WHEN I MENTIONED DISTRICTS I'D
LIKE TO POINT OUT DISTRICT.
TWENTY TWO THERE ARE QUITE A BIT
OF STOCKPILES MY OWN DISTRICT
THE THIRTY TWO DISTRICT A
342-328-3120.
THRE ARE JUST FOR A HANDFUL BUT
THERE'S QUITE A FEW.
THE DISTRICTS THAT ARE THAT ARE
RIGHT IN QUESTION AND AND WE
SHOULD ALL BE CONCERNED ABOUT.
AND IF I MAY CONTINUE.
SB FOUR FIVE ATTENTION
DEMONSTRATE THAT 85% 21100% OF
THESE GRANNIES CAN BE MADE --
NEW BY ADDING A REJUVENATED HER
IN A PROCESSING PLANT AND RETURN
TO THE STREET THAT IT CAME FROM.
SIMILAR WORK IS CURRENTLY UNDER
WAY IN COMPANIES IN INDIANA AND
NEW YORK AND WE ALWAYS KNOW THE
CALIFORNIA'S ALWAYS A LEADER BUT
WE NEED TO PLAY CATCH UP ON THIS
GAME.
IN ADDITION TO REDUCING A
LOOMING ENVIRONMENTAL PROBLEM
THAT COMES FROM HAVING THE PILES
IN CLOSE PROXIMITY TO
NEIGHBORHOODS AND SCHOOLS AND
THERE IS BENEFIT BY NOT HAVING
TO TO MIND THESE AGGREGATE SITES.
AND HALL THE MATURE TO ASPHALT
PRODUCTION FACILITIES OFTEN FROM
DISTANT LOCATIONS.
AND I'VE BEEN MADE AWARE THAT IN
OUR COMMUNITIES PEOPLE ARE
COUGHING AND BLEEDING AND THE
ENVIRONMENT IS GETTING WORSE.
WE MUST DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT
AND THIS IS OUR OPPORTUNITY THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES WILL
MANAGE THE PILOT PROGRAM PROJECT.
SELECT THE SITES TO BE TESTED
AND PREPARE A THOROUGH
ENGINEERING AND ENVIRONMENTAL
ANALYSIS FOLLOWING ITS
COMPLETION.
WE HAVE BEEN IN COMMUNICATION
WITH THE COUNTY FOR LAST YEAR
AND JUST LAST WEEK THE COUNTY OF
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES.
CAME TOGETHER AND THEY VOTED TO
SUPPORT MY BILL.
THIS IS AN AND BUSY -- AMBITIOUS
EFFORT I REALIZE THAT BUT GREAT
THINGS HAVE OFTEN COME WITH AN
IDEA.
IF WE CAN TURN BACK LIKE --
DAVID PACKARD A GROUNDBREAKING
COMPUTER APPLICATION IS GARAGE
IN SAN JOSE.
AND WITH THE OUR CASE.
WE'RE DOING THE SAME THING WE
ARE TRYING TO FIND THE BEST WAY
TO GO TO THE FUTURE TAKE CARE OF
OUR ENVIRONMENT.
TAKE CARE OF OUR ROADS AND WE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY RIGHT NOW.
I WOULD LIKE NOW TO TAKE YOUR
QUESTIONS AND SB FOUR OH FIVE
AND I HAVE MISTER JOHN CORPORAN.
FOR MANUAL ADJUSTING NEWS HERE
IF YOU HAVE ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS AND I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
CENTER -- OF CENTER -- ARE YOU
ACCEPTING -- THE AMENDMENTS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
YES SIR I THANK YOU AND WE'LL
HEAR QUESTIONS -- FIRST OF ALL
ASSN THE PUBLIC SPEAKERS IN
FAVOR OF THIS.
SPEAKERS THAT WANT -- TO SPEAK
IN FAVOR WE'D LIKE TO HAVE OUR
PUBLIC TESTIMONY ON THIS I AM
LIMITED TO TWO MINUTES PER
PERSON.
SO -- SPEAKERS IN FAVOR AT THIS
POINT.
THANK YOU VERY CALMLY WITH THE
LA COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
IN SUPPORT.
LLOYD LEVINE WITH THE WESTERN
PAVEMENT MAINTENANCE ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
MATT CRIMMINS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA THAT A CONFERENCE OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CAN YOU DON'T WHO
DROWNED THE CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL LABORS IN SUPPORT.
PHILIPPE IF WENT TO SOME BEHALF
OF THE ASSOCIATED GENERAL KALACH
SO SINCE THE CESSATION OF
GENERAL CONTRACTORS THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS IN FULL
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR TODD
BLOOM SIGN FOR THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
THANK OTHERS SPEAKERS IN FAVOR.
OKAY -- WE LIKE TO HEAR FROM
OPPONENTS ANY OPPONENTS TO THIS.
BILL THIS IS SB FOUR OH FIVE TO
A YEAR.
NO OPPONENTS HERE DO WE HAVE
QUESTIONS FROM OUR COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE A MOTION -- FOR AND
SECOND.
OF QUESTIONS SENATOR DODD -- YES
CENTER HI I'M ORDER MAYBE FROM A
TECHNICAL STANDPOINT ARE THERE
ANY OTHER PLACES I USED YOU
MENTION A COUPLE STATES HERE
THEY'RE WORKING WITH THIS.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER COUNTRIES
AROUND THE WORLD THAT ARE DOING
JUST THIS AND THAT'S QUESTION
NUMBER.
ONE QUESTION NUMBER TWO IS HOW
LONG IS THIS PILOT.
LET ME TURN IT OVER TO JOHN
COCHRAN FOR THE TECHNICAL SIDE
AND THAT.
IT IS RESEARCH.
YES SIR CAN YOU AND YOUR
INTRODUCED HERSELF.
ANSWER CENTER DODGE QUESTION.
JOHN CORCORAN PRESIDENT A MAN
WHO JUST INK -- AND WE SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
LIMITED WORK THAT I'M AWARE OF
HAS BEEN DONE IN OTHER COUNTRIES
SAW THEY DO HAVE SOME A COUPLE
PROCESSES IN EUROPE.
ART BUT PRETTY MUCH IN THEIR
INFANCY STAGES SO I'M UNAWARE OF
ANYTHING THAT HAS BEEN DONE
WIDESPREAD IN EUROPE.
OKAY ANY OTHER QUESTIONS AS OUR
SERVER WILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU CHAIR I
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO CARLY YOU MENTIONED SENATE
DISTRICT TWENTY TWO WHICH IS MY
DISTRICT AND I AGREE AND I THINK
THIS IS A FANTASTIC IDEA I JUST
HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS.
ARE WHEN THERE'S A PILOT PROGRAM
IT IMPLIES WE'RE TRYING TO SEE
IF SOMETHING WORKS -- AND DO WE
KNOW -- OF OTHER ISSUES THAT THE
OTHER STATES THAT YOU MENTIONED
HAVE COME ACROSS IN THE REASON
I'M ASKING IS.
IF SOMETHING DOESN'T WORK WHAT
IS PLAN B. TO ENSURE THAT IT
GETS TAKEN CARE OF AS ELLIE
COUNTY GOING TO TAKE CARE OF
WHATEVER GOES WRONG OR WHO'S
GONNA BE RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT.
LET ME RESPOND TO THAT JUST A
LITTLE AND I'LL HAVE JOHN CORK
AND FOLLOW THROUGH.
AS YOU KNOW -- YOU JUST HEARD
EVERYONE IN SUPPORT.
AND THIS IS A PROGRAM WITH THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES THERE --
EXCITED ABOUT IT AS I AM.
BUT THE ISSUE HERE IS THE NEW
TECHNOLOGY THE ISSUE IS TO TO A
REDDIT KATIE'S THE ENVIRONMENTAL
ISSUES THAT THE SURROUND ALL
THESE DISTRICT.
SO THE TECHNOLOGY TECHNOLOGY
THAT'S HERE WE HAVE TO GRASP IT
AND GO FORWARD WITH IT.
CHAU -- ANYTHING ON THE
TECHNICAL SIDE I LET GO AND JOHN --
ADDRESS AT COMMITTEE MEMBER
RUBIO GOOD QUESTION AN ODD
COUPLE THINGS.
EVEN THOUGH IT'S A RUBIO PLEASE
SENATOR RUBIO ARE SENATOR RUBIO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION.
AND BASICALLY WE'RE DOING A
PILOT PROJECT TO DEMONSTRATE.
MORE TO THE LOCAL AGENCIES IN
CALIFORNIA OF THE VIABILITY OF
THE HIGH RAP ON THERE'S
OPERATIONS RIGHT NOW SIMILAR TO
THE TECHNOLOGY THAT'S BEING
PROPOSED.
ARE BEING DONE BY BROOKS
CONSTRUCTION IN FORT WAYNE
INDIANA.
OVER FIVE OR SIX YEAR PERIOD.
A PREDECESSOR TO THIS OUR OUR
PROCESS WAS CALLED SITE CLEAN
DAVID DOT DID QUITE A BIT A WORK
ON IN THE LATE EIGHTIES AND
NINETIES FOR THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES.
IN FACT ONE OF THE STREETS
NINETEEN YEARS OLD IS ALL ON
MELROSE AVENUE IN FRONT OF ALL
PER MONTH STUDIOS ARE PERFORMING
VERY WELL.
SO EVEN THOUGH THE TERM PILOT IS
MORE IN LINE TO DO ANY OF THE
CURRENT TESTING AND
QUALIFICATIONS AND ALSO DO WHAT
HASN'T BEEN DONE BEFORE.
A QUANTIFICATION IN GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTIONS AND OTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES ARE.
EVEN THOUGH THE PRODUCT HAS BEEN
USED BEFORE THESE THINGS NEED TO
BE MAY BE BROUGHT UP TO SHOW THE
CURRENT STANDARDS BEING MET.
AND ALSO ALSO WITHIN
COMPENSATION THE ENVIRONMENTAL
REDUCTIONS -- IMPACT REDUCTIONS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE SALT PROCESS
SENATOR.
THANK YOU I JUST IN THE
BACKGROUND INFORMATION BUT I
THINK IT'S A GREAT IDEA THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS SO
CENTER STONE I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN -- SENATOR ARGILLITE AS
WANT TO COMMEND YOU AND
COMPLIMENT YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD -- AND THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT -- THAT I THINK
CALTRANS SHOULD HAVE BEEN TAKING
A MUCH MORE PROACTIVE ROLE OVER
IN THE IN THE PAST -- PAST
DECADE WITH THE THE SUCCESSFUL
PASSAGE OF SB ONE OVER BILLION
DOLLARS GOING TO BE USED.
TO REPAY OF OUR ROADS WHICH ARE
FALLING APART -- THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
AND JUST TO CLARIFY THE RECORD
IN A NEW YORK AND IN INDIANA.
THE THE TO CRY IN 1100% OF THE
ASPHALT THEY RECYCLE IT SO THERE
IS A MODEL OUT THERE THERE'S
BEEN PROVEN TO BE SUCCESSFUL --
I'M FROM RIVERSIDE COUNTY WHICH
IS ONE OF THE FASTEST GROWING
COUNTIES IN THE STATE IN FACT
THIS ONE OF THE FASTEST GROWING
COUNTIES IN THE COUNTRY.
AND WHAT WE'VE SEEN TO BE A RATE
LIMITING STEP TO REPAIRING AND
BUILDING NEW ROADS IS A SHORTAGE
OF AGGREGATE -- AND I THINK IT'S
NOT JUST IN SOUTHWEST RIVERSIDE
COUNTY IN THE COACHELLA VALLEY
MIGHT BE EVEN STATEWIDE AND SO
THIS IS GOING. TO TO HELP SOLVE
THAT PROBLEM OF AGGREGATE WHY
NOT REVIEWS -- IN AN
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY WAY --
THE ASPHALT THE COULD BE
COMPLETELY UTILIZED AS WELL AS I
MET WITH A COMPANY THAT ALSO.
RECYCLES TIRES AND USES PARTS OF
THE TIRES A PART OF THE NEW
ASPHALT WHICH ADDS TO ITS
LONGEVITY IS WATER IN PERFECT
PERVIOUS STATUS -- AND ACTUALLY
ALLOWS FOR A SMOOTHER RIDE SO --
I COMMEND YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD HALF I CANNOT LIKE COULD
BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR AND THAT
THE CORPORATE COMMA MOVE YOUR
BILL.
EVER MOTION THANK YOU THE OTHER
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
OKAY -- CENTERS MORE NO MORE
QUESTIONS YOU WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE AT YES YOUR CHAIR MISTER
CHAIR I WOULD JUST LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR ALLOWING ME TO
BRING THIS.
FORWARD IT AFFECTS ALL OUR
COMMUNITIES AND I THINK THIS IS
OUR START TO GO AHEAD AND TELL
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY THAT WE
CAN WORK N THE ENVIRONMENT ARE
ROACH AND WE CAN'T BE AN EXAMPLE
FOR THE REST OF THE COUNTRY.
AND THE PROTECTION OF OUR
CHILDREN IN THE IN THE
ENVIRONMENT HERE IS SO VERY
IMPORTANT AND I THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEVERAL CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE.
MOTIONS FOR APPROVAL SENATE BILL
FOUR OH FIVE BY SENATOR
ARCHULETA THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY.
CENTER AS WELL ALL RIGHT WELL I
BATES HI BATES AYE DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE I'M AROUND.
MORRELL AYE ROTH.
ROTH AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER SKINNER AYE
STONE AYE STONE AYE AMBER.
AMBER I WILL COST ME -- CASKEY
AYE.
IS THERE A THAT PASSES ON A 12-1
VOTE -- WILL BE REFERRED
ENVIRONMENT QUALITY THANK YOU
SENATOR.
I THINK -- WE'RE GOING TO GO
BACK AND WE HAD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR CAN WE
CALL THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT
COUNTER PLEASE ON THE CONSENT
CLENDAR CONSISTING OF FILE
ITEMS.
ONE THREE FOUR CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE
SKINNER SKINNER AYE STONE ON
STONE I AMBER.
AMBER HI.
THERE.
OKAY THANK YOU THE A TWELVE
DESERVE OUT.
OF WE ARE NOW GOING TO ADJOURN.
THE REGULAR COMMITTEE MEETING.
AND RECONVENE AS A JOINT
INFORMATIONAL HEARING SENATE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE AND
SENATE BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE.
NUMBER TWO